(audience cheering)
Here we are.
I'm loving the new show, and I wanna get into all of it,
but of course, I took a step back
because I love people's bodies of work.
I was wondering if I could ask you
about some of your projects
that we've all loved over the years.
Drew Barrymore can ask me anything.
Oh my god!
Well-
How did I never get to work with Drew Barrymore
in all my projects?
That's the question.
I don't understand how we never got lined up, you know?
Well, there is still time.
Okay. Okay.
There you heard it, folks.
You've been in so many things that I absolutely love.
Let's get into them.
I'd love to be a fly on the wall
in a favorite game I like to play called Behind the Scenes.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
Here we go.
"Talk Soup."
Oh yes.
Look at that baby face.
Yes. Yes.
That was some hair.
It was basically just a clip show
where you'd look at all the daytime talk shows,
and at first it kind of started like
a very straightforward show,
and then we were like, well,
there's no way we can take any of this very seriously,
and it just started to get bananas.
I remember going down to Disneyland,
and they ended up putting me in the Disneyland parade.
So suddenly I had ears on,
trying to be cool sort of anti-culture "Talk Soup" guy,
but when you got the ears on...
That doesn't mean I don't want tickets to Disneyland.
Let me be clear about that.
But I-
You're like, I'm equal opportunity in my ears.
Exactly.
Okay, tell us about the incredible remake
of a beloved classic with Harrison Ford and Julia Ormand,
"Sabrina."
Ah, "Sabrina."
Yeah, it was my first, you know, movie opportunity.
We shot it actually out in Glen Cove, Long Island.
I had this white tuxedo on half the film,
and down in Long Island the bluefish start running
around April or May,
and I love fishing,
and I would go with my pole onto the waters edge.
And I'm in that white tuxedo down by the shore
trying to catch bluefish,
and I finally landed one at the very moment
'cause they were always waiting,
and they were finally like as soon as I got it up,
this scaly, slithery beast in my hands,
they're like, "Greg, we need you now."
And I go up on the thing and covered in fish scales,
and I got an earful from the costume department,
but that was-
Oh well.
My best story from "Sabrina."
Okay, your Oscar nominated role, "As Good as It Gets."
Yeah, I remember going to the Oscars with,
I took my parents, and it was great.
You know, honestly it's just such a blur.
I didn't even know, like suddenly my mom's like,
"Honey, how are we getting there?"
And I was like, "I don't know."
And then there was a limousine that pulled up,
and I looked through the window,
and I'm like, oh my god, this is the most horrific limousine
I've ever seen.
I think there was like a jacuzzi in the back of it.
And I was like...
And was bumping into like the garage
and trying to circumvent our driveway.
And I was like, okay, there's no getting around,
the show's starting in an hour.
I usher my wife, mom, and dad.
My mom's like, "Oh look, there's a disco ball."
And it was so mortifying
because he got to the show,
and I just remember thinking,
why can't I have a cool car like everyone else?
(Drew laughing)
'Cause life always throws those comedic curve balls.
Yeah, I guess.
Okay, "You've Got Mail."
Yeah.
(audience cheering)
Nora Ephron.
I wasn't chosen to do the movie.
Then I went, and she said, can we get breakfast at,
you know, EAT, is that what it's called?
Yeah, I it's AKA for let me get you in my web, I think.
Yeah, I think you're right, actually.
She was kind of,
'cause it's such a cute little place
in the upper I think east side,
and you know, you go in there,
and it's like, what are you gonna do?
After you sit down, I'm having a lovely breakfast with Nora.
Of course, by the time I was halfway through my coffee,
I'm doing the movie.
She knows.
Yes, because AKA spiderweb EAT.
Exactly.
WEB AKA EAT.
DUH.
Duh.
I'm gonna go straight into the next movie I love so much,
and you are such a savior in it.
You have a heart of gold in this movie,
"Little Miss Sunshine."
Oh yeah, thanks.
(audience cheering)
Yeah.
The most dangerous movie I've ever shot.
It's like me driving that bus.
There's no green screen.
We're on a highway.
There's cameras.
We didn't own the highway,
so there are people driving around, just looking at us,
going, "What the hell's going on here?"
So we just made it up as we went along,
but that kind of independent guerilla filmmaking
was kind of a gem of its time.
They don't do that
as much anymore.
Yes.
I love it.
I wanna turn the tables.
I wanna ask Drew Barrymore about "Fever Pitch"
'cause I always like that.
Oh.
Yeah.
Oh, well that is a very special film for me
because we were a part and witnessed
the breaking of the Curse of the Bambino,
81 years at that point the Red Sox hadn't won,
and the film was about-
Were you there at that game?
Yes!
Oh my gosh.
We filmed, we filmed the end of the movie
on the mound in St. Louis,
and we thought we were gonna jinx them.
We were like, oh, we're gonna be the thing
that gets in the way of this team winning.
And then we're filming the whole season,
and then also Jimmy Fallon, who is the lead,
fell in love with my producing partner, Nan,
who's my best friend in the world,
and now they have two kids and-
I didn't know that.
Yes!
(upbeat music)